this article basically highlights how
more than a trillion dollars
of crypto assets have vanished both gone
done
in just the last six months i think
november was the peak
so um that's happening by the way in
everywhere the private market and public
market okay only crypto just to be clear
when they pull it out are they putting
it into something else that
is obvious well here let's let's there's
another article right here um natalia's
gonna put up so 40
of bitcoin investors are now underwater
on their investments 40
okay
so it's down huge i think it's down 55
from its november peak
now leia you probably know the number
where it is exactly at the minute but i
think it's under 30 000 today unless it
creeped up what's the number it's
hovering i mean i've seen it at 29 i've
seen it at 32. okay so it's right around
there so i got my facts right great to
our stat guy so leia make sense of
what's happening right now november was
a peak 2020 we printed out five trillion
dollars people were like holy [ __ ] the
dollar's becoming worthless coveted
lockdowns everything
um crypto boom escalate bitcoin
everything everything everything 2021
was the year of nfts i never even heard
an nft now it's like nft this nft that
you have every schmuck on the street
telling you to buy an nft pump the
brakes leia make sense of what's
happening in the bitcoin and crypto
markets yeah i mean ultimately the fed
just flooded this system with money
right you mentioned it unprecedented
amounts of money people were putting
their stimulus checks into bitcoin and
naturally there was a bull market going
on you had the halving back in 2020 um
generally a bull market tends to that's
the bitcoin halving so the amount of the
of the supply cuts in half naturally a
bull market tends to follow after that
um there's a lot of things going on the
fed flooded the system with money people
had surplus cash to throw into it so
with all that surplus cash plus an
impending bull market naturally it's
going to go up now we're at a point
where the fed is starting to take um you
know inflation seriously um and people
don't have that surplus cash it's
actually being pulled out we're also
during also going through times of crazy
geopolitical issues where there's a war
going on in um in europe which the us is
heavily involved in markets don't like
war people definitely like to withdraw
their um withdraw their assets from the
ones
when there's chaos doesn't that lead to
like we need some stability some
security
let's go into bitcoin let's go because
bitcoin is still a risk on asset right
like it's only 13 years old and so
naturally people are going to withdraw
their money from it like during times of
uncertainty do you feel comfortable
holding bitcoin yet
yeah i'm good i mean right you don't
want to you're uncomfortable i don't i
don't have all my assets in bitcoin i've
got less than five percent of my net
worth in crypto so i'm good like right
so but you're uncomfortable with the
idea of holding it during times of um
instability bitcoin is going to
eventually be an uncorrelated asset but
it's not an uncorrelated asset yet so
it's still going to be affected
uncorrelated asset is so related to
geopolitical events so the market in the
public market so bitcoin is still
correlated to geopolitical events
okay so you're saying them that the
world is in chaos the world is in
shambles and bitcoin inflation if i
didn't make that clear inflation is is
um a 40-year high right everything is
more expensive fuel gas everything is up
milk bread everything is up do people
really want to be investing into
something like bitcoin right now which
they don't really understand it's a bit
of a risky asset no they want to hold
that money because of inflation so i
think that's the biggest problem so
going back to what happened you had an
impending bull market given we had the
bitcoin halving um so it's like a four
year cycle and then the fed flooded the
system with money people put their
stimulus checks into bitcoin they had
surplus cash and naturally that's not
that's not healthy that's not good
economics and now the market not just in
bitcoin or crypto but the market
generally um as antonio was saying is
feeling that the s p 500 nasdaq
everything is just
down can you go build a little on what
you said which is
see things from this perspective
so bitcoin generated a lot of
millionaires right a lot of people with
money that money throughout time let's
say 2015 to 17 has been you know 2x 3x
4x and then that money has been
distributed throughout other
cryptocurrencies like ethereum you know
solana whatever
so what's happening now it's like we
created a whole you know cryptocurrency
market with all of these coins and new
companies and new chains existing
and what's happening at this moment
is that people all the crypto
millionaires all the people that have
money will now again reinvest bitcoin in
bitcoin right like buy bitcoin at a a
great retail price
and basically when the market comes up
again
the first coin that will win and two or
three x will be bitcoin right again
that's like an easy notion to understand
so what people sometimes like try to get
caught on is like okay is bitcoin
defensible or ethereum defensible
throughout these you know cycles of
course it is because the the level of
community that has built throughout the
years is massive so there's no
like
as i said in the beginning
the money generated from the first and
second and third generation of
bitcoiners
allowed the crypto industry to exist
now that money you know has been wiped
off because all of those
cryptocurrencies were you know either to
zero or they have no utility
now the people with money will go back
again to bitcoin we'll reinvest in
bitcoin bitcoin will become again the
number one currency and you know by
january as i was telling you we'll get
to you know 60k or 50k again and you
know get to number one again so
one of the things you just said that i
want to highlight you said like the
billionaires the crypto millionaires
they're they're buying this [ __ ] half
off yeah correct like they're not that's
how it works if they believe in bitcoin
or they believe in crypto and they're
multi multi millionaires and they're
billionaires they're like let the fool
sell i'll take is like the michael is
over the world exactly and the um mike
novogratz
when there's blood in the streets
[Music]